the Huntsman winters war is a prequel
sequel middle coal something cool to
Snow White and the Huntsman a movie that
I liked more than most I think it was a
visually stunning movie with some good
action sequences but it didn't have very
much replay value unfortunately when I
watched it a second time this film is
directed by the visual effects
supervisor on the first film and this
one's about the Huntsman Chris Hemsworth
who's out on a mission to find the evil
mirror because it's evil and it does bad
things to people convinces them to kill
themselves and their friends he's joined
by Jessica Chastain who he shares a
forbidden love with because the Evil
Queen Freya
played by Emily Blunt has completely
forbade love in her kingdom no as I said
I like the first one a little more than
most people so I can understand why the
majority would think that this sequel is
completely unnecessary because most
people were disappointed by that first
movie and felt that that movie was even
a little bit unnecessary but out of all
the characters in that first film I had
the most fun with the Huntsman character
played by Chris Hemsworth so it was kind
of interesting to see where he would go
it was a natural progression in my mind
to see where that character could go
unfortunately he's not going anywhere
interesting or compelling because this
movie is pretty messy and boring to be
honest which is unfortunate because
there's so much they could do with this
story there's so much fun that could be
had and you could tell they were trying
to go for a Princess Bride vibe
sometimes very swashbuckling romance
adventure swordplay weird creatures in
the wilderness and sometimes it works
there are some good action scenes the
one I enjoyed the most being this bar
brawl that was all sound effects and no
music it felt very intense because of
that choice and I liked it but as a film
this goes nowhere really it starts off
with emily Blunt's character and her
sister played by Charlize Theron having
this tragedy occur and then she turns
into this Evil Queen that can summon ice
out of her fingers she wants to steal
everyone's young make them her own army
thus making sure that no one else in her
Kingdom is happy so long as she isn't
happy and her character and her
performance oh man I feel bad saying
this I love Emily Blunt I think she's
one of my favorite actresses actually
but she was very bad in this movie her
performance reminded me of Eddie
Redmayne and Jupiter ascending a lot of
slow
methodical talking with occasional
outbursts just really didn't work and it
started to grate on my nerves after a
while also the excuse for why Charlize
Theron's character returns there was
really no attempt to explain how it was
just like we need Charlize Theron
can you reprise your role yes okay great
you were amazing in fury road please
come back oh you're come back okay cool
cool cool now just put her in the movie
somehow and since Kristen Stewart was
smart enough to not sign on for this
movie they use a body double for her and
they constantly refer to her character
but they never show her character except
from behind with this body double that
you just know is not her and so there
really is no way you can get invested in
that part of the story because you never
see Snow White they just keep talking
about her because Christmas Stewart was
like no I'm not going to do this movie
the thing I like the most about this
movie was the camaraderie between the
Huntsman character and two dwarves as
well as two female dwarves there was
some good humor there they did try to
inject humor in this movie they tried to
make it fun they were going for a bit of
a Princess Bride vibe I felt anyway and
sometimes it did work sometimes I did
chuckle a few times there are a few okay
action sequences but the story as a
whole from Evil Queen that is dealing
with a tragedy to Charlize Theron
suddenly back to Snow White who's a body
double to Hemsworth looking for this
mirror to forbidden love it just didn't
really mesh it was too many things
happening at once and it wasn't very
well directed in regards to tone and
harnessing tone it is a good looking
movie and since the director is a visual
effects supervisor I can understand why
it would be good looking and this being
his first movie I give him major kudos
for trying hard but it just doesn't
really mesh well I'm gonna give the
Huntsman winters war a c-minus I think
if you're a big fan of the Snow White
mythos or the snow white films or of
course a Snow White the Huntsman movie
it's worth checking out maybe but
definitely not in theaters for everyone
else just skip it and have a nice day
hopefully you have a nice day please
it's nice outside right now so have a
nice day guys thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
my nice